et donald trump et ses négociateurs 2020
n'aura pas été seulement l'année de
lakovic 19
elle sera aussi celle des accords de
branche
[Musique]
vous êtes renversé par un homme de 92
ans qui perd le contrôle de son véhicule
deux ans et demi plus tard vous vous
imposez comme un espoir français du
tennis fauteuil objectif est les jeux
paralympiques de paris est vrai que le
sport m'a toujours sauver le tennis
c'est que c'est mon sport
bon il ya un fauteuil mais je vais
essayer et en fait je me suis rendu
compte que ça allait c'était
suffisamment physique pour moi j'ai une
vie de sportif de haut niveau je
m'entraîne tous les jours c'est devenu
ma vie la raison de me lever le matin
j'avais toujours ce vieux rêve de petite
fille de faire du sport de ma vie est
finalement là c'est ce que je réalise
avec les gens vont manger un autre
combat on ma vie qui est celui de la
sécurité routière s'agit d'un projet de
loi qui vise à mettre en place des
thèses attitude pour tous les
conducteurs pas seulement les seniors on
a un contrôle technique de son véhicule
il faut un contrôle technique de sa
personne et sa l'état doit doit imposer
loi sur ce sujet là
[Musique]
dernière journée dieu procéda ça traoré
classardes adama traoré mort en 2016
après son interpellation par des
gendarmes des gens d'à qu'elle accuse
d'avoir tué son frère ils la poursuivent
en justice pour diffamation
[Musique]
emmanuel macron appelle les anglo saxons
arrêté de bloquer les exportations de
vaccins et des ingrédients nécessaires
pour les produire le président français
qui participe ce soir un tome est à
porto fera avec ses homologues européens
réunion au cours de laquelle devrait
s'imposer le sujet de la levée des
brevets sur l'essai romantique au vide
il fait débat au sein de mieux la france
se déclare finalement favorable à l'idée
l'allemagne elle émet des réserves
[Musique]
manifestation au brésil contre les
violences policières après une opération
entre et anti drogue qui a fait au moins
25 morts dans une favela de rio la plus
meurtrière de l'histoire de la région
le coup de filet de la police s'est
transformée en bain de sang l'onu
demande une enquête indépendante et
impartiale
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france deuxième jour
d'audience pour à ça traoré est
poursuivi en diffamation pour avoir
publié une tribune dans laquelle
figuraient les noms des gendarmes
qu'elle accuse d'être responsables de la
mort de son frère en 2016
compte rendu de ces journées depuis le
tribunal de paris avec notre reporter
katia technique ça traoré comparaissait
au tribunal pour diffamation a signé par
les trois gendarmes qui ont interpellé
son frère adama traoré
cela fait suite à une tribune de juillet
2019 qu'elle avait écrite
reprenant le j'accuse d'emile zola sur
l' affaire dreyfus dans cette tribune à
les accuser d'avoir tué son frère adama
en l'écrasant du poids de leur corps
elles les sites et nominativement d'où
la procédure en diffamation intenté par
les trois gendarmes
le procureur aujourd'hui a expliqué
qu'il fallait distinguer droit à
l'indignation de la diffamation et que
la tribune était disproportionnée quel
qui a été la justesse du combat qu'elle
entendait mener
en revanche l'avocat d'hassan traoré
maître yassine bouzrou a longuement
plaidé à expliquer en quoi la tribune
que sa cliente utilisaient des bases
factuelles de la procédure
je vous propose d'écouter maître bouzrou
et assa traoré il y a une dizaine de
médecins qui ont trahi sur ce dossier
qui affirme très clairement que
l'interpellation a causé la mort et pas
seulement des médecins français
également des médecins américains
notamment le médecin qui travaille sur
l'affairé floyd des médecins légistes
brésiliens des médecins français des
médecins belges désigné par les juges
d'instruction donc nous avons seulement
des médecins choisi par la famille mais
également des médecins choisis par les
juges d'instruction qui indique
clairement que si adama traoré n'avait
pas été interpellé par les gendarmes il
ne serait pas mort
donc ma cliente dénonce dans un texte
qui s'intitule j'accuse tous ces
éléments factuels précis parce qu'elle a
raison de le faire en se basant sur des
éléments objectifs
les gendarmes sont responsables de la
mort de mon petit frère comme mon avocat
maître yassine bouzrou viens de le dire
tous les éléments
tous les éléments sont là et tous les
éléments mettent en cause les gendarmes
aujourd'hui la justice française doit
prendre ses responsabilités et nous
devons aller tous devant un procès
public
aujourd'hui la sphère adama traoré est
une affaire qui est devenue nationale
sont des questions qui n'appartiennent
plus qu'à la famille traoré mais qui
appartiennent à la france entière les
deux jours de procès sont donc écoulés
en l'absence des trois gendarmes et le
délibéré a été porté au 1er juillet
paris durcit les conditions d'entrée sur
le territoire français
les voyageurs en provenance de sept pays
supplémentaires devront à leur tour
respecter une période de quarantaine
obligatoire de dix jours lors de leur
arrivée
c'est le cas de la turquie du sri lanka
du pakistan ou encore du qatar où le cor
n'avait reçu circule activement
ils rejoignent sur cette liste le brésil
l'afrique du sud l'inde le chili et
l'argentine
emmanuel macron appelle les anglo saxons
fera arrêter de bloquer les exportations
de vaccins et des ingrédients
nécessaires pour les produire cela
permettrait selon président français de
favoriser la circulation du sérum et de
renforcer la solidarité vaccinale
mondiale il s'est exprimé à son arrivée
au sommet européen qui se déroule ce
soir à porto au portugal
emmanuel macron qui s'est félicité de la
stratégie d'exportation de vaccins de
l'union européenne on écoute aujourd'hui
les eaux glauques son bloc
beaucoup de ces ingrédients et des
vaccins aujourd'hui 100% des vaccins
produits aux états-unis d'amérique vont
pour le marché américain en europe sur
un peu près cent dix millions de
produits à date nous avons exporté 45
garder 65
nous sommes les plus généreux au monde
aujourd'hui emmanuel macron qui a répété
être favorable à l'idée de lever les
brevets sur les vaccins une proposition
de l'administration biden qui a conduit
plusieurs pays à se positionner sur le
sujet sujet qui fait débarque au sein de
l'ue que l'allemagne est réticente et
c'est le président français se montrent
aujourd'hui plus en clans il n'en a pas
toujours été ainsi
martial peugeot nouveau rétropédalage de
l'exécutif face à la pandémie
lors de l'inauguration du centre de
vaccination de la porte de versailles à
paris hier emmanuel macron s'est dit
favorable à la levée des brevets je suis
tout à fait favorable
à ce qu'il y ait en effet
cette ouverture la propriété
intellectuelle vous m'avez entendu de
dire il ya un an quand nous avons dans
ses initiatives
extra une position adoptée depuis un an
selon le président de la république
pourtant il y à un peu plus d'un mois
clément bonne le secrétaire d'état
chargé des affaires européennes affirmé
linverse nous partageons votre objectif
c'est d'ailleurs la france et c'est le
priant de la république qui l'ont porté
en premier faire du vaccin un bien
public mondial
maintenant il faut sortir des slogans
pour atteindre cet objectif
si lever les brevets avait une
quelconque utilité aujourd'hui nous le
ferions immédiatement mais ça ne sert à
rien aujourd'hui
je le dis très clairement une ligne de
conduite maintenu jusqu'au parlement
européen
le 28 avril dernier l'ensemble des
eurodéputés de la république en marche
voté contre l'amendement en faveur de la
levée des brevets sur les vaccins un
changement de cap radical donc du
gouvernement
dénoncé par la france insoumise papaye
donne à part les minima qu'on s'aligne
victoire totale pour nous tous qui nous
sommes mobilisés dans le monde entier
pour les licences libres sur les vaccins
hypocrite emmanuel macron vous êtes
battu contre cette levée des brevets sur
le vaccin pour servir vos amis du fric
des laboratoires pharmaceutiques
la france a voté contre à l'organisation
mondiale du commerce
by john vous inspire parfait taxer les
riches le principal intéressé a tenu à
clarifier la situation sur son compte
twitter je maintiens françois ruffin
lever les brevets n'a pas d'impact à
court terme c'est autorisé l'export qui
est urgent l'europe exporte 50 % de sa
production
les etats unis 0 c'est nous qui livrons
les pays qui en ont besoin
si vous défendiez la solidarité vous
devriez en être fier un débat qui
s'invite dans les discussions entre les
états membres de l'union européenne
réunis aujourd'hui à porto est toujours
concernant les vaccins l'om s accorde
son homologation d'urgence ou
séromantique ovide chinois sinopharm
premier vaccin chinois recevoir son feu
vert
l'organisation mondiale de la santé le
recommande pour les personnes de plus de
18 ans
nicolas steurs jeunes confiante au
lendemain des élections locales la
royaume uni les résultats complets sont
attendus demain en cas de victoire de
son parti la première ministre écossaise
et chef du parti indépendantiste snp
promet aux écossais un nouveau
référendum d'autodétermination le moment
venu elle s'est exprimée depuis glasgow
après l'annoncé de sa réélection dans sa
circonscription avec plus de 60% des
voix
je suis très heureuse et extrêmement
confiante
nous sommes sur la bonne voie pour une
quatrième victoire électorale
consécutive où et nous avons la capacité
de former un nouveau gouvernement
c'est une réalisation extraordinaire
pour tout parti politique est de son
côté boris johnson se réjouit de la
conquête par son parti conservateur d'un
bastion aux travaillistes et propres
exceet dans le nord-est de l'angleterre
une première en près de 50 ans hazel
poule
la candidate à jean mortimer a recueilli
près du double des voix de son
adversaire je vous propose d'écouter le
premier ministre britannique
les premiers résultats sont connus
depuis ce matin et il reste encore
beaucoup à faire
c'est encore tôt mais les résultats sont
très encourageants jusqu'à maintenant et
je pense que c'est vraiment parce que
nous nous sommes concentrés en tant que
gouvernement sont nos priorités les
priorités de la population et que nous
avons repoussé la pandémie aussi loin
que nous le pouvions
le manifestation au brésil après une
fusillade meurtrière les protestataires
se sont rassemblés aux abords du
quartier général de la police
il demande des investigations après ce
coup de filet policiers à rio
ils visaient des trafiquants de drogue
présumés qu'il a fait au moins 25 morts
25 morts dans une favela
l'onu demande une enquête indépendante
et impartiale
le récit et de quentin l'eau claire
attention certaines images peuvent
choquer un véritable bain de sang ce
jeudi matin dans une favela de la
métropole de rio une opération policière
contre des trafiquants de drogue a
tourné à la fusillade
une nouvelle tragédie pour les habitants
de ce quartier défavorisé
le gamin est arrivé blessé est ici dans
la favela
personne ne jette quelqu'un dehors il
est resté ici et quand la police a vu le
sang elle est entrée en client ou et il
est où est il
j'ai juste eu le temps de mettre mes
enfants derrière moi et ils ont tué le
gamin dans la chambre je n'avais jamais
vu autant de sang il y en avait partout
dans la favela un manque de respect pour
la police scientifique
bref une absurdité totale les habitants
de la favela jacarezinho ont rapporté l
afp que des corps inanimés baigner dans
des mares de sang dans les ruelles de
nombreux cadavres ont ensuite été placés
dans un véhicule blindé de la police
présente sur place
lo ng réseau d'observatoires de la
sécurité publique dénonce des actes de
barbarie et rejette la faute sur le
nouveau gouverneur de l'état de rio de
janeiro
aujourd'hui les habitants ont vu leurs
maisons transformées en lieux de torture
où des gens ont été exécutés un garçon a
été exécuté et placé sur une chaise en
plastique au milieu de la rue le doigt
dans la bouche dans une pose moqueuse
pour que tout le monde puisse le voir le
gouverneur claudio castro qui est
officiellement en fonctions depuis cinq
jours défi le tribunal suprême fédéral
et la police de l'état est entré dans la
favela pour se livrer à une
démonstration de force
cette opération de police sanglante
s'est déroulé en dépit d'un arrêt de la
cour suprême interdisant les raids
policiers dans les favelas durant la
endémie sauf circonstances
exceptionnelles les forces de l'ordre
ont précisé que l'action de ce jeudi
faisait suite à une enquête contre 21
membres du gang commando rouge en
conférence de presse les chefs de la
police ont assuré que l'ensemble des
protocoles d' usage d'armes à feu
avaient été respectées une précision qui
intervient alors que la première
personne tuée lors de cette opération
était un policier
je tiens à préciser que la police n'agit
pas sous le coup de l'émotion
afin qu'il n'y ait aucun doute je
rappelle que pour mener une telle
opération
nous planifions beaucoup il nous suivons
de nombreux protocoles les trafiquants
de drogue que met une série de délits
recrutement de mineurs pour travailler
dans le trafic de drogue
attaque de train et nous avons constaté
plusieurs incidents dans la communauté
de jacarezinho
le jeudi 6 mai 2021 fera date au brésil
cette intervention policière devient la
plus meurtrière de l'histoire de l'état
de rio de janeiro selon l'institut y
garer paix groupe de réflexion
spécialiste de la sécurité et du
développement
la police de rio est responsable du
décès de 453 personnes entre janvier et
mars 2021
les colombiens ne décolère pas s'ils
sont toujours dans la rue malgré l'appel
au dialogue lancé par le gouvernement
depuis fin avril et protestent contre la
réforme fiscale plus largement il
dénonce la politique menée par le
président et 22 quai hier ils ont bloqué
des routes de bogota dans le quartier de
taussat kyo à l'est de la capitale
des bougies ont elles été allumée chez
en hommage aux victimes des violences
policières
depuis le début du mouvement une
trentaine de civils sont morts plus de
850 ont été blessés ici nous rendons
hommage à toutes ces vies perdues et à
celles qui ont disparu pour la colombie
pour l'avenir de ces jeunes qui veulent
lutter pour un avenir mais
nous sommes réunis ici ce soir pour
représenter le peuple colombien pour que
le gouvernement comprenne que nous ne
sommes pas les méchants
nous ne sommes pas ceux qui tuent nous
sommes ceux qui luttent et qui crient
pour la paix et spécialiste de
l'amérique du sud notre journaliste
meriem la règle il revient sur ce
mouvement de contestation écouter les
forces de l'ordre donc ont tiré à balles
réelles sur les manifestants on a pu
voir à travers les réseaux sociaux des
images terribles avec des individus qui
ne semblait pas représenté un quelconque
danger abattu à bout portant par les
forces de l'ordre
tous les jours on a eu des vidéos depuis
dix jours résultat l'eau angie est
humble honnête qui recense les victimes
a recensé donc en dix jours 37 morts
tués par balles au moins 89 personnes
portées disparues plusieurs centaines de
blessés dont une vingtaine des borniers
et une dizaine d'agressions sexuelles
malgré tout cela malgré le danger donc
représentent les manifestations et
malgré la pandémie qui l'est qui
n'épargnait pas du tout la colombie les
mobilisations se continue de plus belle
les manifestants estiment que je cite le
gouvernement est plus dangereux que le
virus
la colère contre la réforme fiscale qui
était à la source de ce mécontentement
s'est transformé en brasier contre le
gouvernement l'onu a exhorté israël à
mettre fin à toute expulsion forcée de
palestiniens à jérusalem est les nations
unies inverti ce que ces actions
pourraient constituer des crimes de
guerre l'organisation ajoute que
jérusalem-est fait toujours partie du
territoire palestinien occupé sur lequel
le droit humanitaire international
s'applique jérusalem est au coeur d'une
vive bataille devant les tribunaux sur
le sort de familles palestiniennes
menacé d'éviction au profit de colons
israéliens bataille judiciaire qui se
manifeste un de nombreuses
manifestations et des heurts ces
derniers jours
dimanche nous étions à la cour suprême
et le juge nous a dit vous devez
admettre que cette terre est la
propriété des colons en échange de votre
protection
notre réponse aujourd'hui a été sans
appel
nous ne reconnaîtrons pas cette
propriété comme appartenant aux colons
nous vivons dans ces maisons depuis 65
ans et nous ne les quitteront pas de
notre vivant c'est une terre arabe
palestinienne du gouvernement jordanien
et nous habitants de ce quartier nous ne
pouvons en aucun cas admettre que cette
terre est la leur elle est à nous la
terre est à nous la terre est à nous
nous n'avons pas été en mesure de
trouver un compromis avec d'autres
partis donc le tribunal nous a informé
aujourd'hui par conséquent le tribunal a
fixé une audience d'appel en présence de
trois juges mardi prochain et politique
africaine mène la france la question se
pose au regard de l'actualité au tchad
cette intervention militaire française
ont été menées dans le pays et le chat
n'est pas le seul où la france se montre
active tant abonnés que ce soit d'un
point de vue géographique ou
stratégiques le tchad occupe une place
centrale sur le continent africain
la france possède des bases militaires
et depuis l'indépendance du pays en 1960
l'armée française y est intervenu à sept
reprises un record en afrique des liens
forts et illustré à nouveau ces derniers
jours lors des funérailles du défunt
président idriss déby un leader au
pouvoir pendant 30 ans et qui a toujours
coopérer activement avec les présidents
français notamment sur l'épineuse
question sécuritaire la région étant
historiquement prise pour cible par des
groupes terroristes tels que boko haram
c'est pourquoi emmanuel macron lui a
rendu un hommage appuyé au moment de ses
obsèques
cher président
cher maréchal
cherry driss jeu
nous voilà réunis devant votre dépouille
après trois décennies à la tête de votre
pays et tant de combats livrés avec un
discours mal reçue par les manifestants
qui s'opposent au conseil militaire de
transition présidée par le fils de
l'ancien président ses détracteurs l'ont
perçu comme un adoubement du
gouvernement français en dépit de
quelques réserves finalement exprimée
par emmanuel macron à son retour de
djamena depuis les critiques s'amplifie
contre la position française un
sentiment qui semble prendre de
l'ampleur sur tout le continent
que ce soit au sénégal où des magasins
auchan avait notamment été pris pour
cible en mars dernier ou au mali où une
partie du peuple conteste la présence
des forces françaises antiterroriste un
ressentiment qui touche désormais une
grande partie des anciennes colonies
françaises comme le détaille cet article
de marianne résultat de plusieurs
décennies d'une politique opportuniste
parfois jugée comme néo colonialiste
c'est dans ce contexte que nicolas
sarkozy a répondu à une interview dans
les colonnes du point
l'ancien président et défend son bilan y
compris en libye et remettent en cause
la pertinence de l'opération barkan au
sahel
je reconnais la grande complexité de ce
sujet car j'observe que quand la france
ne fait rien elle est accusée d'inaction
et que quand elle intervient elle est
accusée d'ingérence
quant à la françafrique nicolas sarkozy
estime qu'elle est terminée mais force
est de constater que la perception d'une
partie des africains diffère de celle de
nos dirigeants français un climat déjà
perceptible en 2017 lors de la première
visite d emmanuel macron sur le
continent africain au burkina faso
fraîchement élu le président français
avait fait comme ses prédécesseurs avant
lui la promesse d'une rupture
[Musique]
les crimes de la colonisation européenne
incontestable et fait partie de notre
histoire
je me reconnais dans les voix d'albert
londres et dans un régime qui ont
dénoncé des milliers de morts des
chemins c'est beau je n'oublie pas que
c'est voir alors des minorités en france
comme en europe
et si le devoir mémorielle sur le rwanda
ou sur la mort de thomas sankara
constitue une étape importante dont le
renouveau des relations entre la france
et l'afrique francophone
les discours se heurte bien souvent aux
actes revenir sur un passé douloureux
n'exempte pas pari de rendre des comptes
sur ses liens actuels avec des pouvoirs
parfois autoritaire un discours à deux
vitesses d'emmanuel macron qui
fonctionne bien difficilement sur un
continent éprouvée par 50 ans de
politique française sur son sol et pour
régis souper analyste géopolitique et
directeur exécutif d'interpol conseil la
france va continuer de soutenir le
nouveau pouvoir tchadien
le tchad a toujours été cette fois sans
faute qui permet justement à ce que le
ciel ne tombe pas si vous voulez dans
une espèce de dia distant tropicales
dont ce qui fait que le président idriss
déby j'ai pas le défi du père a toujours
été soutenue parce qu'effectivement
c'est un homme de guerre c'est le chef
se fait chef militaire de première de
premières envergure et donc la france a
toujours soutenu le président deby en
dépit juste moi ont du caractère
autocrate et voire dictatorial donc de
son pouvoir
c'est un président et un gouvernement
c'est un régime qui a toujours été
soutenue parce que n'était bien sûr en
pointe et ça il faut le dire la
méridienne a toujours été la plus
aguerrie la plus forte la plus
professionnelle façon d'y animer et face
au terrible ce qui fait que justement en
dépit de la nature du régime
idriss déby a toujours su compter sur
les pouvoirs français successifs de
mitterrand jusqu'à emmanuel macron et si
vous voulez faire un soutien qui est
stratégique est qui et qui fait que j'ai
c'est moi idriss déby fils a fait
l'actuel président aussi bénéficiera
encore d'un soutien je dirais souhaité
mesurer de la part du gouvernement
français
un retour en france où la crise révèle
des élans de solidarité temps et énergie
mise au profit des autres notamment des
étudiants parfois en grande difficulté
financière et en détresse psychologique
une initiative a vu le jour son nom
remplir le frigo reportage d'aujourd'hui
demory avec serial bois effervescence à
l'association ont rempli le frigo
ce jeudi marque le début de la
distribution des produits récoltés par
l'association dans le 3e arrondissement
de la capitale
une cagnotte a permis de recueillir plus
de 60000 euros
grâce à cette initiative de 1500 paniers
alimentaires pourront être distribués à
paris lyon toulouse et marseille
pat fruits et légumes variés ou encore
gel douche composeront notamment ses
paniers les étudiants beaucoup souffert
et on a beaucoup plus de travail donc
plus rentrée d'argent
on a vu sur d'autres distributions
alimentaires qui avait énormément de
monde que la demande était constante et
que ça les schistes et pas
malheureusement donc on a décidé de
venir en aide un peu à ces étudiants là
et à ses autres associations pour les
bénévoles on est parti mais chercher sur
les réseaux sociaux
ça a été très simple à partir du moment
où on a commencé à poster des des postes
on disait que une distribution
alimentaire allez allez être présente le
civet tout le monde a répondu présent
directement n'a pas eu besoin de les
harceler pour venir c'était quelque
chose de naturel et ça fait vraiment
plaisir à voir dans cette situation
actuelle solidarité et échanges sont les
mots d'ordre au sein de l'association
l'action séduit et permet aux étudiants
de se changer les idées
quand ils vont venir quand ils vont
récupérer leur sac on va essayer d'avoir
le sourire une musique on va vraiment
essayer d'avoir une discussion avec eux
justement pour les faire sentir bien et
que pendant ce moment où ils viennent
dans un moment qui est quand même
assez difficile parce que quand même de
venir chercher des denrées il cherchait
un bide de l'aide se passent pas très
facile ce genre de choses ça permet déjà
de sortir de chez soi par rapport au
confinement et ces gens ça fait vraiment
plaisir
et en plus de ça va tomber sur des
étudiants super sympa qui font toutes
ces actions est de manière générale sur
la période c'est vraiment toutes ces
actions cumulées pour aider les
étudiants qui permettent un peu de ba de
relativiser sur la période en soit on
est comment on en arrive à être en bonne
santé on arrive à avoir en plus de ça
pas mal de coups de pouce pour nous
aider donc vraiment c'est ce que du
positif pour cette première étape à
paris la file d'attenté ne désemplit pas
seule condition pour accéder à ces
distributions la présentation de la
carte d'étudiant en une journée
350 étudiants ont pu bénéficier de ces
paniers repas
il dénonce l'utilisation par les forces
de l'ordre d'hélicoptères pour
surveiller les manifestations un
lyonnais régulièrement présent dans des
rassemblements citoyens a décidé de
porter l affaire devant les tribunaux
aux côtés de son avocat il juge cette
pratique illégale comparable à
l'utilisation de drones luis carvalho
avec un grain de sel empêché les
hélicoptères de la gendarmerie de filmer
pendant les manifestations
c'est l'objectif d'un lyonnais de 38 ans
il s'est pour cela rapprocher du comité
de surveillance des violences policières
de lyon lassé de se savoir filmer depuis
les airs lorsqu'ils participent à une
manifestation
il a ainsi décidé de lancer une
procédure juridique
accompagné de son avocat maître
lantheaume c'est une requête par un
manifestant qui a été introduite au
tribunal administratif de lyon contre la
préfecture du rhône par rapport au fait
que celle ci fait voler un hélicoptère
de la gendarmerie a
lors de toutes les manifestations que
connaît la métropole et il s'est
interrogé sur le cadre juridique dans
lequel cet hélicoptère intervenait une
requête légitime selon m lantheaume qui
s'interroge sur le cadre légal de cette
pratique
alors il n'y a pas d'égalité au fait que
le un hélicoptère survole une
manifestation en tout cas à priori là où
il ya un vrai problème par contre c'est
sur le fait que cet hélicoptère puisse
capter des images très précises
d'individus de citoyens qui sont en
train de manifester et puissent
éventuellement enregistré ces images
en tous cas de manière certaine les
transférer au poste de commandement et
les images est en visionner ensuite par
les services de police de gendarmerie et
les renseignements généraux ou que
sais-je
les inquiétudes réside notamment dans
l'utilisation qui pourrait être faite de
ces images ce qu'on comprend c'est qu'en
réalité un hélicoptère qui paraît si
haut et simplement en mesure de voir des
formes ou autre dont il peut clairement
vous identifier et avec la
reconnaissance faciale qui arrive on
sait pas forcément l'usagé qui sera fait
de l'image les manifestants qui pour
l'immense majorité n'ont rien à se
reprocher mais ne font que défilé dans
la rue selon le comité de surveillance
des violences policières de lyon la
capitale des gaules est la ville qui
compte le plus grand nombre d'heures de
vol en hélicoptère pour des missions de
police m lantheaume lui se montre
confiant quant à l'issue du litige et
espère avoir gain de cause dans quelques
mois et c'est la fin de cette édition se
retrouve dans une trentaine de minutes
pour un nouveau journal à total art
[Musique]
notre société vit un moment très
important dans la lutte contre les
violences de l'intimé violence de la
maison il y à chaque année 300 mille
personnes victimes de violences
sexuelles
70% des plaintes classées sans suite et
un nombre de condamnations
d'ailleurs en baisse mais autour de 1000
condamnation par an nous devons
progresser de deux manières
la première c'est par la loi et ensuite
progresser parce que nous un peu long
des pratiques professionnelles
protectrice la justice à sa part dans
cette impunité
comment souhaitez vous la faire évoluer
nous devons être concret pour que la
protection ne soit pas un mot mais une
réalité
et y'a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire que notre peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sort du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend
sable est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
des sous le numéro i l'uniforme c'est
quand même des hommes comment ces
mecs-là arrive à dormir la nuit là aussi
je pense qu'on a vécu quelque chose
d'inouï tg les gens qui s'étaient des
valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
des gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas la double hic
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct
il y a quand même la liberté je vous
remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
en inde il n'existe pas de statistiques
officielles sur les enfants perdus ou
séparés de leurs parents
selon certaines informations un enfant
disparaît toutes les huit minutes dans
le pays
cet enfant est avec vous ou allez vous
elle est avec toi et lui
il est aussi avec toi il vous accompagne
je ne sais pas je connais pas son nom
selon la commission nationale des droits
de l'homme 44 mille mineurs
disparaissent chaque année
la police déclare qu ils sont 88 mille
enfants le fonds des nations unies pour
l'enfance qualifie cette situation de
génocide et donne le chiffre de 12
millions d'enfants
[Musique]
alexandre roubtzoff est un enfant de
saint pétersbourg haugen l'immense
capitale de la russie impériale en avril
1914 il débarque à la goulette
je n'avais imaginé dans les brumes et le
raffinement glacée de ma ville natale
que je trouverai ici tant de grâce de
simples élégance de poésie dans des
lieux et parmi des êtres quand je ne
savais à peu près rien aux offres plus
de 30 ans il attend donc du paysage de
tunisie parce qu'il était tombé amoureux
de ce pays de cette lignée n'avait
absolument pas de voyeurisme dans le
regard de roxas mais une une empathie
totale
ce sont eux les bédouins montagnards ou
du désert qui sont bonhomme les raffiner
tandis que nous autres nous sommes
mesquin et inélégante si ce n'était pas
tant à l'intérieur du pays dans l'âme du
pays et c'est cela qui veut transmettre
alexandre roubtzoff aura pas jusqu'aux
derniers jours de sa vie laissant
inachevé le tableau de la mosquée de
sidi mehrez vénéré entre troupes au
centre de tunis
ultime geste d'amour pour le seul pays
qui aura vraiment compté pour lui
bonjour bienvenue dans ces caches dans
les séries policières vous avez toujours
le bon flic et le méchant flic
cette fois ci dans ces caches vous aurez
deux méchants
[Musique]
bonjour aujourd'hui nous allons nous
demander comment on va se terminer cette
crise bonjour estelle bonjour olivier
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans ces caches
cela fait plus d'un an maintenant que le
coc vide 19 est apparu dans nos vies
crise sanitaire crise économique comment
tout cela va se terminer si on va en
parler à dans cette émission et pour
cela en deuxième partie nous serons en
liaison depuis les états unis la
caroline du nord plus précisément avec
un max keiser ancien trader et animateur
de l'émission kaiser report sur rt
internationale
l'arrivée du colis de 19 à ravager bon
nombre d'économies oblige les pays à
mettre sur la table de nombreux plans de
relance mais tu as an parfois les
finances publiques à rude épreuve
rien qu'en france la crise devrait
coûter 4 124 milliards d'euros d'euros
au pays entre 2020 2021 et 2022 et à la
clé cette année un déficit public de 9 %
les détails avec le tiroir cash
d'antoine basse
[Musique]
quelle trace locaux vides les stratic
sur le long terme on s'avancerait un peu
trop en ayant une réponse formelle à
cette question si on commence à
apercevoir le bout du tunnel grâce à la
vaccination
il est évident que l'économie a pris un
sérieux coup dans les dents
mi-avril persie a posé un chiffre sur
cet état de fait 4 124 milliards d'euros
c'est ce que coûterait cette crise à
l'état français sur trois ans entre 2020
et 2022
un chiffre énorme et étonnamment précis
qui prend en compte les dépenses
engagées comme le chômage partiel le
fonds de solidarité de coûts des mesures
sanitaires ou les impôts qui ne sont pas
rentrées dans les caisses
à cause de la récession de 2020 de 8,2
pour cent
la france n'est pas la seule dans ce cas
en europe sauf que d'autres pays se sont
retrouvés plongés dans la crise avec des
déficits de départ beaucoup dans
important avant le coup vis de la france
avait déjà une dette de 100 % du pib
quand l'allemagne n'était qu'à 60% par
exemple on n'était pas tous sur la même
ligne de départ et on ne sera donc pas
tous égaux pour remonter la pente
on pourra se consoler un petit peu en se
disant qu'il y a pire que nous si on
traverse l'atlantique le déficit
budgétaire américain n'est pas mal non
plus 4500 milliards de dollars sur deux
ans 600 milliards rien qu'en mars
dernier des chiffres si gros qu'il
laisse forcément imaginé un impact
durable sur le monde et son économie
olivier c'est vrai que quand on regarde
ces chiffres on peut parfois avoir le
sentiment que tout cela va mal finir
pour autant l'oscd a par exemple table
sur un rebond de l'économie mondiale de
5 6% est cette année et 4 % l'an
prochain alors cette crise va-t-elle
réellement laissé des traces sur le long
terme par exemple est ce que dans dix
ans on observera toujours les stigmates
de cette crise bien sûr bien sûr puisque
je vous ai distincts phase c'est ainsi
une fin de modèles ont depuis 20 ans on
fonctionne sur la bête que ce soit la
dette publique mais la dette privée
aussi aux états unis pour les citer vous
avez tout marche avec de la dette la
dette étudiante qui
sur des niveaux qu'on n'avait jamais
atteint la dette pour l'automobile qui
est sur des niveaux jamais atteints la
dette des cartes de crédit parce que
savait que les américains ont cinq ou
six cartes de crédit sur lequel vous
avez cinq ou six découvert et donc vous
avez une dette qui est énorme et cette
dette là il faut pas croire
elle est à 0 % ou 0 % + cdc veto de 2,2
d'intérêt qui sont entre 8 et 15 16 même
20% sur certains emprunts donc
évidemment ça coûte très cher tout ça et
il faudrait que il y ait des hausses de
revenus mais comme sous la présidence de
monsieur obama
il a complètement mis par terre la
classe moyenne américaine
ça va être compliqué de repartir donc
vous dis aujourd'hui vous avez de la
dette qui est mise vous avez de la
monnaie qui est émise
tout ça pour camoufler le le manque de
croissance et dans dix ans vous aurez
des chiffres qui vous montreront que la
reprise de croissance n'était pas là on
a qu'on dit continuer à s'endetter et
que donc les monnaies seront par terre
alors peut-être avant dix ans même et
et voilà donc non le la croissance
explosive en 2020 2021 enfin en 2021 en
2022 qui rattrapait ou et qui ferait que
dans quelques années on s'aperçoit fut
petit qui a eu qui s'est passé quelque
chose en 2020 me paraît tout à fait trop
optimistes merci olivier tout de suite
la deuxième partie de cette émission
et cette semaine nous sommes en liaison
depuis à la caroline du nord aux états
unis avec max keiser ancien trader est
journaliste pour rt international
bonjour max bienvenue dans ces caches
bonjour c'est un plaisir de vous voir un
plaisir d'être ici
un mec c'est la crise économique liée à
l'arrivée du cosy de 19
aura-t-elle raison de nos économies la
crise du coc vite fait partie d'une
crise aurait plus globale dans notre
économie qui a commencé en 2008 lorsque
le système mondial s'est arrêtée puis on
a tenté d'inonder l'économie mondiale en
liquidités mais ça n'a pas fonctionné
nous avons toujours une économie
mondiale qui est en détresse et qui
s'amenuise
la politique des banques centrales ne
fonctionne pas donc la crise continue et
empire la crise du coc vide n'est qu'une
partie du beaucoup plus grande crise
libyenne réaction la copie dans une
crise plus large
on en a parlé maintes et maintes fois
ici
la lacc au vide n'est qu'un des unes des
états de la dégradation de l'économie
depuis 2008 en 2008 il ya une une
fracture une première fracture mais déjà
on avait commencé en 2000
en 2000 les banques centrales avaient
déjà mis de l'argent sur la table
beaucoup d'argent en 2008 elles ont
réitéré
elle est là dans un ensemble parfait
puisque la banque du japon la bce
les américains et on a essayé de
camoufler les choses on a essayé de de
créer une illusion de croissance avec
cette dette est illusion qui est tombé
au moment du coc vide puisque là c'était
encore plus compliqué parce qu'il en
fallait beaucoup beaucoup pour essayer
de maintenir les choses et et on vous
l'avait dit ici plusieurs fois le jour
où il y aura un pépin les banques
centrales feront du all in et elles ont
fait du all in et et elle continue et je
pense que c'est pas fini parce que
maintenant elles ont mis le doigt dans
le pot de confiture et que vous leur
tirez pas facilement et donc on est
parti pour probablement une phase 2 de
création monétaire débridée qui se
terminera comme elle doit se terminer
c'est à dire mal max les banques
centrales sont les seuls responsables
selon vous je suis d'accord avec olivier
pour dire que la crise remonte aux
années 2000 lorsque les banques
centrales étaient très actives pour ce
qui est de l'impression d'argent
ça remonte encore a plutôt cela fait
partie de ce modèle néolibéral qui
échoue de manière catastrophique
tous ces problèmes sont bio banque
centrale est elle